it's another week of children going to
school in zimbabwe and doing nothing
constructive because there are no staff
the government suspended thousands of
teachers for three months without pay
for going on strike demanding more money
we are not learning we are now playing
there are no teachers we are now roaming
around
the government has offered teachers a 20
pay increase payment of part of their
salaries in u.s dollars and other
incentives including free education for
their children and loans for housing but
unions rejected the offer saying it's
still not enough the government here
employs about 140 000 teachers
nationwide it's not known exactly how
many of them are on strike the education
department says they can be replaced
with thousands of unemployed teachers
currently looking for work
union leaders believe politicians are
out of touch with reality
those who are supposed to manage our
education
have found an escape route where their
own children are leading in private
schools in elite private schools and
some of them are learning in exotic
learning centers beating australia u.s
among other listeners but so the public
school is now so much neglected because
they are not affected their sons and
daughters are not there so they don't
worry
munara dimasiwa sells gas from his house
to supplement his income
he and other suspended teachers want at
least 540 us dollars a month
right now they're earning less than 100
a teacher gets about 80 u.s a right now
and you need to break that amount into
transport allowance there is the housing
allowance
and the basic salary is also included in
that 80 us
economists warn paying salaries in
american dollars will fuel inflation
with no side so far willing to budge
there is little to no learning taking
place in many of zimbabwe's public
schools haru mutasa al jazeera